de patrick bruel
quand tu es bon soir bonsoir noir pour
batman album il s'appelle entre deux car
toutes les chansons qui censure cet
album date de l'entre-deux-guerres sauf
le temps des cerises qui remonte à la
commune lance alors la base ça devait
être un album avec deux ou trois duos et
finalement c'est un double cd avec 12
duos et 12 chansons interprétées par
vous alors duo pas n'importe qui un duo
avec johnny hallyday jean jacques
goldman jean louis aubert sandrine
kiberlain emmanuelle béart nous laurent
voulzy charles aznavour asie alain
souchon francis cabrel et même la
délicieuse danielle darrieux absolument
et patricia kaas est de la merde
elle faisait déjà un album de reprises
choix excellent au départ vous aviez 200
chansons et comment vous avez fait ça a
été terrible non bah j'ai un peu
dévaliser les magasins me disent que je
suis arrivé pour les vacances de noël
on avait pris deux maisons avec la
famille je suis arrivé avec une valise
dans les valises il y avait tous ces cdg
orly voilà les vacances ont peut-être
être merveilleuse où terry pour vous
mais voilà ce qu'on va écouter et j'ai
mis j'ai mis ces cd ça va de salles et
de damian fréhel en passant par marie
chevallier midget charles trenet alors
la qualité des arrangements est
incroyable non mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai ça on n'a pas reçu juste avant
qu'il arrive mais ça il ya des morceaux
qui sont entrés swing façon un peu hot
club de france
ces mêmes grappelli et django reinhardt
c'est tout à fait cet esprit là j'ai des
choses plus réalistes comme